Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
After reading a physics textbook on the laws of
fluid motion, with a little effort, we can make
a virtual world come alive by writing a computer
program that contains these laws, resulting in
beautiful fluid simulations like the one you
see here. The amount of detail we can simulate
with these programs is increasing every year,
not only due to the fact that computer hardware
improves over time, but also, the pace of progress
in computer graphics research is truly remarkable.
And, this new paper promises
detailed spiral-spectral fluid and
smoke simulations. What does that mean?
It means that the simulations can be run in
a torus, spheres, cylinders, you name it.
But wait, is that really new? When using
traditional simulation techniques, we can just
enclose the smoke in all kinds of domain
shapes where the simulation takes place.
People have done this for decades now. Here
is an example of that. So, what is new here?
Well, let’s have a look at some results
and hopefully, find out together.
Let’s start with the details first.
This is the new technique. Hmmm.
I like this one. This is a detailed simulation,
sure, I’ll give it that. But we can already create
detailed simulations with traditional techniques,
so, once again, what is new here? You know what,
let’s compare it to a traditional smoke simulation
technique and give it the same amount of time to
run, and see what that looks like. Wow. That is a
huge difference. And, yes, believe it or not, the
two simulations run in the same amount of time.
So, it creates detailed simulations. Checkmark.
And, it has not only the details, but it has
other virtues too. Now, let’s bring up the heat
some more. This is a comparison to not an older,
classical technique, but a spherical-spectral
technique from 2019. Let’s see how the new method
fares against it. Well, they both look good,
so maybe the new method is not so much
better after a…wait a second. Ouch!
The previous one blew up. And the new one,
yes, this still keeps going. Such improvement in
just about two years. So, it is not only fast,
but it is robust too. That is super important for
real-world use. Details and robustness. Checkmark.
Now, let’s continue with the shape of the
simulation domain. Yes, we can enclose the
simulation within this domain where the spherical
domain itself can be imagined as an impenetrable
wall, but it doesn’t have to be that way.
Look. We can even open it up! Very good.
Okay, so it is fast, it is robust, supports
crazy simulation domain shapes, and even better,
it looks detailed, but are these the right
details? Is this just pleasing for the eye,
or is this really how the smoke should
behave? Well, the authors tested that too,
and now, hold on to your papers, and…look! I could
add the labels here, but does it really matter?
The two look almost exactly the same. Almost
pixel perfect. By the way, here you go.
So, wow, the list of positives just keep on
growing. But we are experienced Fellow Scholars
here, so let’s continue interrogating this method.
Does it work for different viscosities? At the
risk of simplifying what is going on, the
viscosity of a puff of smoke relates to how
nimble the simulation is. And, it can handle
a variety of these physical parameters too.
Okay, next, can it interact with other objects
too? Some techniques look great in a simple,
empty simulation domain, but break down when
placed into a real scene where a lot of other
objects are moving around. Well, not this new
one. That is a beautiful simulation, I love it.
So, I am getting more and more convinced with each
test. So, where is the catch? What is the price
to be paid for all this? Let’s have a look.
For the quality of simulations that we get,
it runs in a few seconds per frame. And
it doesn’t even need your graphics card,
it runs on your processor. And
even that, this is blazing fast.
And, implementing this on the graphics-card could
very well put this into the real-time domain,
and boy, getting these beautiful smoke puffs
in real time would be an amazing treat.
So, once again, what is the price to be paid
for this? Well, have a look. Aha! There it is.
That is a steep price. Look. This needs
tons of memory. Tens of gigabytes.
No wonder this was run on the processor, this
is because modern consumer graphics cards
don’t have nearly as much memory on board, so
what do we do? Well, don’t despair - not even
for a second. We still have good news. And the
good news is that there are earlier research works
that explore compressing these datasets down,
and it turns out, their size can be decreased
dramatically. A perfect direction
for the next paper down the line!
And, what do you think? Let me know in the
comments below what you would use this for.
And, just one or two more papers down the line,
and maybe, we will get these beautiful simulations
in our virtual worlds in real time. I can’t wait.
I really cannot wait. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!